oh that can't exclusive
yup our 98.3 we hit five Liz lay live
in-studio this dude is performing
tonight celebrity theater about to be
turns out we got yg fo why every time I
smell you dog you smell like you've been
smoking on that gas though Oh amen
tonight you performing live a celebrity
theater man I mean I've been blessed be
able to see if do your thing live you
get super turns up man what kinda people
expect you have not seen you yet life oh
you ain't seen me live we fin have a
party on stage you show me I'll be ready
to get wet be ready probably getting
jumped on oh nice well yeah all that
kind of stuff is going down tonight you
feeling we finna we're gonna go with a
now have fun hey and if you're like a 7
or better females be ready to get jumped
on to come back to the hotel we got my
fire roll nice little luxury little - so
you ain't gone then don't worry about
it's gonna be a fun night that's what I
talked to on the phone the other day man
you got this mixtape that you're working
on with Nipsey Hussle
yeah and you didn't tell me what it was
called can you can you do nothing yet no
you from you my boy honey can we go back
from Vegas if I had a name I would have
told you okay good
how many joins deep are you so far I've
got like two workers for it on my side
you send me that's how we doing it we're
gonna make sure that halfway like it's
gonna be like a half of my type of
Records and then have this type of
breakfast then we're just gonna go in on
a moon door like that and put the tape
together you know when you say your type
of Records if someone wanted to ask you
about me because I kind of feel like you
were the first person there's a hot
sound right now it's kind of come out
the west you know 2 Chainz got the
mustard beat on the album now you know I
feel like you and Tiger but I think you
kind of had it first
you never lost you as well as we like
you know what I like it's a [__] all you
wanted us yes Marcy yeah yeah Tiger
[__] ooh I'm just uh I said um nah but
I wanted to ask you man um considering
that that's kind of I mean like if you
go to a club on the west coast your type
of record
pretty much what you're gonna hear not
stop me I mean I mean you go hear my
[__] but you don't hear my records you
feel me and bu author of the burgers is
poppin it sound like your record in the
United States you gonna hear all the
records but being like like the personal
interview feeling from the west coast
it's gonna be me and you know cuz you
hear the Tigers and whoever else
following it the [__] I'm doing that's
what you gonna do animosity towards time
too right now no I'm just speaking the
truth no animosity at all I mean not
know if you in psycho sorry that vog huh
if you attack like Randy to each other
in hallway viola well son shout out to a
shout out to yg fo-fo hundred we are
we're really under in these streets me
know what these people deem an the
mixtape is coming out
hey man you are like um where's it
summer all the club records you've got
you are you are quite crafty at crafting
these ratchet anthems dogs when you go
into the booth I mean what do you have
to be real high-end drunkard I mean you
know the kids like you so ratchet to
your records in the club I did 18 enough
night last night and played pop it in it
was like WorldStarHipHop one cup hopping
off on the dance floor there it is man
hey makes you get the mixtape out right
now yg 440 degrees you dope tape got
bangers on the front to back and of
tonight it's going down hey let's give a
pair of tickets away right now you don't
listen we'll try to win one soon
celebrity theater tonight it goes down
lots of tickets left we'll come through
man yg in the studio its power ninety
eight point three five lives